these are the two final results we want
to end on okay let's have a look at part
one
they sing explain that's a funny kind of
word to having a maths question but it's
really really simple when you resolve
the initial velocity this is what you
get for X dot so you can say this when
time equals whoops zero for time equals
zero okay
X dot is equal to u cos alpha that's
where we saw that the first time okay
what's the significance of V cos beta
well it's later on at time one whatever
that may be okay so I can say when time
equals time one right when you resolve
that velocity you get this okay but X
dot X dot what kind of a function is it
it's it's constant it never actually
changes the reason why is because
there's no force acting on it right it's
never going to change therefore at these
two times X star should be equal so
there you you can just say from there
really
okay that's it that's sufficient right I
think that's kind of your crucial line
in there now moving into part two all
you're going to do is use this and take
that as an identity right what n are
you're going to use well this is double
angled isn't it okay you're gonna solve
for beta so in place of alpha I'm gonna
say you cause to be done right sub that
everything where am I going to go from
here what direction can you clearly tell
this goal is going in what's that look
like
that's the quadratic formula right see
like oh there's a quadratic hiding in
here of course there is because this
this is u to u cos squared B R minus u
right yeah there's your there's your two
cos square beta minus 1 and that's V cos
beta you rearranged to make your a B and
C for your quadratic equation zero and
then you solve for closed beta ok now
just like any quadratic equation you're
going to get two solutions out you're
gonna get this guy
and after you um signify what's
underneath the square root here and
that's just going to be on to note for
you so okay
so how shall we eliminate one of the
solutions and you know which one you're
gonna eliminate how you gonna do it it's
very similar this right there are
restrictions on here you just need to
identify the right ones okay so I
already know right that'd be nice but
you know what restrictions do I know
about it hmm I think that'd be da hey be
restricted between what values zero and
now I want I want a restriction that is
helpful to me right I want that one's
helpful I want to get rid of this V
minus solution right in other words I
want know what the positive one okay so
a restriction that will help me here is
going to be rather than Z 0 is less than
the middle which is an alpha which is
like well I don't know about alpha yet
either
I should just say it's less than plan to
its lesson plan to write the reason why
is because if that's true but if you
take cause of all three parts of the
inequality you can say well B is going
to be sorry cause beyond he's going to
be positive right because think about
what cos beta looks like between north
and plyo - namely like that okay with
your inability with those polar circles
okay so it's possible that's great but V
- this guy is negative right that
numerator there that particular new red
out of the two solutions okay therefore
since I know that it's meant to be
positive but this is negative I have to
reject that solution okay it's not gonna
work so I can say cos beta is the
positive one only and then
you can take causing versa both sides